pour elle mais dites moi vous qui
promenait son chien a tous les jours
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un à qui le
vénèrent comme ma voix est posée éduqué
en forme le son de ma voix est encore le
seul pratiquement qu'ils lui fassent
part un regarder si daisy au oui fx à
buffet 1,6 et le maître c'est moi hein
quand même ouais t'as peur un petit peu
quand je lève la voix quand tu fais les
choses pas bien je suis encore
pratiquement le seul de qu'il est
vraiment sain chaîne qui est pas très
gentil de nature alors quand vous
trouvez il est approché par quelqu'un
avec ne connais pas ce quelqu'un je
crois qu'il vaut mieux se garer est ce
que tu as et bien du reste puisque ça
nous serve de garder en même temps il
est là quand des gens commencent à venir
à la maison d'une façon régulière
c'est lui qui doit faire le premier pas
c'est à dire que les gens quand même pas
la même quand sont déjà des familiers de
la maison à venir le caresser faut que
ce soit lui qui décide que tout d'un
coup il a accepté quelqu'un et qui va
faire ami ami avec je n'aime pas les
chais qui sont des carpes est celui d'un
moindre sa personnalité il est pas très
gentil qui sait pas faire grand chose
dans la pape qui c'est quoi cet
assassin's creed accès du jambon dessous
en fait c'est une tradition position
d'après les jeunes et il a été bien
gentils comme il est toujours gentille
la droite on off et qu'est ce qu'ils
mangent à parler vous il s'appelle
l'amour et parce que sa façon de marcher
nous rappeler un petit peu ce qu'on
avait vu à tahiti fait part des superbes
filles locales mais en fait on pourrait
l'appeler béni bouffe tout parce que
tout ce que vous lui donnez le mange vu
son apparence physique on pouvait s'en
douter
mais bien que ce chien ne sache rien
faire ou au miracle de la télévision il
écoute très attentivement l'avouer de
son être lorsque tu es trop belle c'est
pas facile
blanc ce que tu es une fille beaucoup
trop belle c'est difficile
ils ont autant rire de lui parler
d'amour tout le
au nom d'abord il serait complètement
affolée car il ya quand même une chose
se réalise c'est quand il voyage c'est
en tentant l'emmène en vacances par donc
pas pour des galas quand il voyage il
est absolument ceux chez qui vous ferait
tout le monde quand il connaît pas il
arrive dans le train il se couche et ne
bouge plus tout le temps que dure le
voyage même si ça dure huit ou neuf
heures à bercy
alors maintenant tu t'assieds alors à
sita montre montre que tu as appris au
moins quelque chose
voilà la récompense des facteurs merci
oui mais alors normalement il met à
porto les petits déjeuners à rivière du
sucre sur le plateau vers le chien a
tiré par le sucre mon thème temple le
plateau du petit lait j'avais alors
finalement pour venir chercher le sud
il a en même temps pris soin du courrier
et des journaux c'est comme ça que la
tradition produit s'était appuyé encore
rester comme comme mélange tard puisque
ça mélange oui non non non je viens
mélange de deux chiennes et pagnol qui
est déjà elle n'était pas complètement
sang bleu et je suppose que son père que
je ne dois pas présenté était un
labrador alors je dis que ce gros chine
pour employer une expression très galles
et un labradoodle
et avez vous déjà eu le cul non parce
que parce que j'aime bien sa présence
j'aime bien le côté le plus costaud bien
ça et je trouve qu'un chien c'est sympa
qu'il soit là surtout un gros nounours
c'est un gros lyon 1 confié mais je suis
contre les gens qui dressent leurs
chiens alors il est là il a tiré le bon
numéro il est heureux de vote
pourquoi vous avez pris un chien on
connaissait sa mère qui était une petite
chienne toute mignonne formidable et qui
faisait des trucs extraordinaires
intelligence ce monstre ordinaire et là
à tel point que j'avais dit aux freins
quitté le père de la mère si un genre
tâche nv déchets j'en veux un en
espérant que le fils voudrait la mer et
voilà j'ai hérité d'une toute petite
boule jaune qui est devenue ma stop et
qui sait rien faire du tout mais qui est
rageant c'est devenu mon chou appris
quelque chose sur vous même par exemple
ou sur d'autres sur les enfants dans la
vie non très renault très honnêtement si
je devais les révoltés je trouve pas
terrible
c 'est pas faire grand chose mais c'est
peut-être ça qui est bien justement il
vit là sa présence et j'aime bien oui
j'aime bien sa densité
je